a no- win situation by rewriting the
rules this is not the only good quote
for the famous Central character in a TV
series called suits Harvey Spectre uh he
is very good at using critical thinking
so that's the reason why we're
mentioning here today he's a successful
lawyer known for his exceptional legal
skills confidence and assertiveness and
Charisma Harvey is the self-proclaimed
best closer in New York City he's
intelligent ambitious and often takes on
cases that no one else wants to take on
due to his amazing critical thinking and
critical reading abilities he's able to
solve problems that other lawyers can't
even dream
of critical thinking is a process of
actively and skillfully conceptualizing
applying analyzing synthesizing or
evaluating information gathered from uh
everywhere or generated by observing uh
experiencing reflecting and reason
reasoning uh in order to fully
understand and communicate a problem as
simply as possible and uh a very good
critical thinker is also uh serves as a
guide to belief and action in many cases
according to the Paul Elder framework
critical thinking involves analysis
evaluation and constant
[Music]
Improvement Aristotle said that it is
the mark of an educated mind to be able
to entertain a thought without accepting
it that's kind of the same thing as
being a good critical thinker because uh
understanding something and uh accepting
it right away takes a lot of skills so
being able to do that uh that's one of
the most uh important qualities of a
successful
person the famous guy uh with the famous
mustache and the messy hair once said
that Curiosity has its own reason for
existing so we should try and look uh
critical thinking based on this
perspective and this is going to teach
us uh this is going to teach us to be
curious about important and relevant
details whether we're solving a problem
at school or we're solving a problem uh
on on our daily
basis though those who think that they
know everything will never be able to
learn anything new being open to new
ideas and knowledge is crucial for
personal growth and development the
world is constantly changing and
evolving and it's important to keep up
with the latest trends and information
it's okay to admit that you don't know
something as long as you are willing to
learn in fact admitting your ignorance
can be the first step towards gaining
new insight and understanding so don't
be afraid to ask questions seek out new
experiences and be more open-minded you
never know what you might
discover and before we dive deeper into
this topic I'd like to introduce myself
I'm Mr arifi I an ESL teacher who will
uh briefly discuss a few things about
critical
thinking there are five relevant matters
that we will discuss here today one is
the definition of critical thinking the
benefits of critical thinking critical
thinking characteristics how to how to
improve critical thinking skills and
examples of critical thinking
abilities among other things there's
this famous quote from Steve Jobs who
says thinking is easy acting is
difficult and to put one's thoughts into
action is the most difficult think in
the
world well a brief definition about
critical thinking is that it's mostly
known about someone's ability to think
about every important aspect of a
problem rationally aiming to understand
the relationship between
facts and one of the best feelings in
the world is the feeling when you
understand something fully when you use
your skills and your critical thinking
abilities to understand a bigger problem
there's a lot of benefits uh if you're a
good critical thinker the first one is
that those people uh find it easy to
solve problems they are self-aware and
they know their skills and abilities
they're more open-minded they're good
communicators and uh when it comes to
solving problems they get very creative
and they have some good ideas how to
solve a problem with less
consequences an open-minded critical
thinker is someone who is open to
hearing all sides of a story avoids
biases and analyzes situations more
clearly they're open to clarifying and
evaluating arguments and evidence
they're also curious about what others
think have empathy for other people and
are open to having their ideas
challenged without getting
defensive by being self-aware
individuals can identify their own
thought processes and biases which can
help them to avoid making decisions
based on preconceived notions or
emotions developing self-awareness can
also help individuals to better
understand their own strength and
weaknesses which can lead to more
effective decision making thus becoming
a better critical
thinker good critical thinking directly
influences the quality and nature of the
messages you send the conversations you
have the decisions you make and the
overall quality of your communication
interactions by developing and nurturing
critical thinking and effective
communication abilities individuals can
significantly improve both personal and
professional experiences leading to
increased success in various Realms of
[Music]
life there are four main characteristics
of a good critical thinker the first one
is attitude a person who thinks
critically will be open-minded value
honesty and have different perspectives
the second one is uh criteria they apply
standardization based on fact sources
and careful consideration they're good
at bringing very solid arguments they
have statements based on clear facts and
data and the last one is their abilities
to draw
conclusion there's a few ideas how to
improve critic critical thinking
skills the first one is to train
yourself to train yourself to think in
Balance the second one is to be aware of
the situation you're in and the third
one is to develop thinking effectively
and efficiently by planning and
organizing your thoughts and also
training yourself daily before every
problem before every
situation and the last way that might
help you improve uh your critical
thinking skills is to become an active
listener because active listening will
help you understand better and will get
you to the core of a problem faster and
in a more effective
way a good example of a critical
thinking ability is being able to
analyze
situations and uh not just to do that
but also to collect information and data
to interpret and to evaluate everything
thoroughly and
carefully uh most of the time people who
have good analytical skills uh work in
uh business and economics they're uh
very high Achievers they have the best
uh the most paid jobs because they use
their mind in a way that uh normal
people
wouldn't example of critical thinking
ability uh another one example is that
those people are huge problem
solvers another example of uh good
critical thinker is that uh their
ability to solve huge problems or to
solve uh
continuous their ability to solve many
problems at the same time solving
problems by conducting analysis while
providing effective Solutions is uh one
skill
that can be considered important when it
comes to critical to solve problems as a
critical thinker you need to follow a
series of steps that involve identifying
the problem collecting information
developing and executing Solutions and
analyzing the results in the
end creative IAL thinking requires one
to be
open-minded to consider the perspectives
of others and oneself to be able to
improve critical thinking skills in the
decision- making process is very
important when mindedness also requires
detaching from one's own beliefs and
considering points of views other than
one's own without bias or self-interest
it is about being open to feedback by
accepting positive feedback and not
rejecting criticism or constructive
feedback without thoughtful consider
consideration another good quality of a
good critical thinker is uh time
management
skills time management is an essential
component of critical thinking as it
allows and follows individuals uh to
allocate their time effectively and
efficiently to achieve their goals
effective time management involves
prioritizing tasks setting goals and
creating a schedule that allows for the
completion of tasks in a timely manner
by managing their time effectively
individuals can avoid procrastination
reduce stress and increase
[Music]
productivity here are some strategies
for better time management one set
priorities identify the most important
task and prioritize them second create a
schedule create a schedule that includes
old tasks and activities third avoid
procrastination by doing that you are
allowing yourself some space and you are
planning uh better before solving the
problems or before doing something the
fourth one is to eliminate
distractions eliminate distractions such
as social media emailing and phone
notifications is a good way to focus on
what's important the fifth one is take
breaks take regular breaks to avoid
burnout and maintain focused and the
last one is uh among other things the
last one is to delegate tasks uh to
yourself and to other people when
possible to free up time for more
important tasks by implementing these
strategies individuals can manage their
time more effectively and efficiently
leading to improved critical thinking
and overall
productivity another example of a good
critical thinker is their abilities to
uh communicate things very very
correctly so they're good communicators
communicating is a process of critical
thinking and uh most of the time uh
these people discuss and share
information with other people to show uh
to show a different perspective of of a
bigger problem uh to show and to
understand something in in a deeper
level that's why students when they want
to do and they want to nail a
standardized test they should be very
careful to understand the main idea of
something and to understand the problem
uh to the very core before they jump to
conclusions or answer any
questions effective communication also
helps to build trust and Foster positive
relationships which are essential for
personal and professional
[Music]
success thank you for watching if you
like our videos make sure to comment and
subscribe for more similar
content till next time take
care